louise marie suzanne étudiante en
sciences humaines à l'université de
laval
vous avez 20 tu ne sais pas si on peut
faire un parallèle entre le comportement
sexuel des étudiantes dans le cadre du
québec et dans le cas des universités
américaines
mais est-ce que vous avez autant de
liberté à ce plan oui on a goûté on
apprend qu on peut faire chez nous ce
qu'on veut et pas de problème absolument
impôts mais c'est personnel
on apprend plus ou moins comme on veut
simplement gsm / ni rien dire j'ai
l'impression qu'ici elle avait la
liberté très grave
sur ce plan là ça se traduit sous quelle
forme
c'est pas un gars une fille
s'ils veulent aller faire l'amour ils
vont enfin pas de venir vous voir dans
vos champs oui les plus inacceptables
l'an dernier c'est interdit mais cette
année elles un dernier a eu des
élections pour ça pour une liberté plus
rares dans l'oeil maintenant alors les
garçons peuvent venir dans nos champs
l'autorisation initiale
il va peut-être non je sais pas des
situations ça demain
une option tout à fait personnel ils
peuvent très facilement revenir dans nos
choix on peut avoir un groupe d'amis oui
le condé rage pour les gens à côté
la face quand on veut alors quand vous
mamad haghighat beauté peuvent dormait
alors à ce moment là des relations
sexuelles si on veut on est on est très
laid mais ça devient une option
personnelle baisse quand on peut faire
un parallèle entre ces relations
sexuelles toulouse et dans le cas de
cette université
et puis le courant de sexualité qui est
en dehors cas il n'est pas une grande
rue de québec ou de montréal où on voit
la filda cinéma un film vantant les
mérites ou les attraits de certains
avouent mais quand un avion les a tous
vu ce que ça joue
est ce que c'est une influence sur la
nasse et c'est plus libre que c'était
quelques-uns beaucoup plus on a même
coup plus alors forcément est pourtant
le seul religieux
c'est une université qui catholique si
on veut mais ça veut pas dire que parce
que c'est comme ça que les étudiants
pratiquent la danse vous avez chacun
votre boyfriend tous les soirs by étudie
nocivité de cydia ce travail est un peu
oui ça se passe vous habitez deux filles
par chambre non non jb chargea de merlin
choix est déjà fort alléchant des
devises sur tradition c'est ce que j'ai
habité l'impression de charmed sommes
donc nous y recevoir un garçon toutes
les nuits en principe mais ça dérange
pour signer monsieur latreille voit pas
appris il doit pas passer entre cépie
âgées d'être fait un peu c'était un ange
à 2 heures du matin pour rentrer puis le
9 juillet la main sur mesure qui me dire
monsieur ce n'est pas cela mais si tu
passes par le porte à côté puis le voit
pommade ou sage il est net et un peu
quelqu'un qui veut amener quelqu'un plus
tard que la recrue m'agace on sortir le
vote
milan michalek baiia ne s'est pas posée
je pense pas aux humains
on s'en fout parce que le mot sexualité
est un problème
à l'université on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
sérieusement c'est pas un problème
bon sinon sans menottes à papa ma fille
sont normaux est ce que vous essayez de
créer une ambiance à travers cet
artifice là je fais allusion à la drogue
il y en a beaucoup que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup qui imprègne ses traits c'est
très répandu comme partout ailleurs je
pense
puis je sais pas
les gens prennent ça comme ils prennent
comme ils prennent la boisson ça se
parle énormément il ya beaucoup de
discussions sur la drogue sur hambourg
sur des sexualités évidemment mais ça
demeure toujours individualiste et puis
si quelqu'un veut entendre
il est lé suzanne vous droguez vous
j'apprends parfois oui mais voilà oui
pis hc et de la cité raison bien précise
et peu de raison précise
c'est ce que d'abord je cherche pas je
ne recherche pas mis souvent se venger
des amis qu'elle me voir bon ok on a
fait c'est toujours à ce moment là mais
pour quelles raisons précises sais pas
c'est pas une évasion que cherchez pas
une libération de mes problèmes c'est
tout simplement parce que ça me plaît
beaucoup d'autres comme son célèbre
petit gars de merouana commune avant
imposition
la sensation que ça donne je trouve ça
très intéressant
c'est pour ça que je reproche apprend
pas beaucoup je recherche pour mais
quand l'occasion se présente sur
facebook c'est pas une invasion pas du
tout c'est tout simplement on voit on
perçoit autre chose que ce qu'on veut
tous les jours ce qui t'intéresse et ses
pratiques et est employé communément ici
je voyais à notre ère pourquoi près
comment est ce que vous payez une sirène
ben moi j'en ai par un éminent lui a
notre mot pour un dollar mais lui ce
parce qu'il sait vraiment où aller alors
regarde la boj a rien eu beaucoup et où
pas l'impression que ça peut diminuer
vos facultés mentales
non pas pour moi qu'est ce que
j'apprends passer ça quand vous
réveiller après avoir filmé tels que sia
de waszak le genre de la mata ou à
l'amphi sur un problème un petit peu
particulier a plus ardue vous avez tout
les mêmes facteurs oui oui pas de
problème de ce côté-là c'est ça ou
l'alcool
pourquoi pas pourquoi l'alcool parce que
c'est pas c'est physique l'alcool la
maintenance révèlent leur plus mal de la
trance pas drôle tandis qu'avec la
drogue on travaille on est bien mais
tout à fait d'accord c'est ce que ça me
fait à moi peut-être à d'autres ça fait
passer l'épaule j'ai posé une question
de milieux de la drogue ou le bois sont
peut-être des amis qui en prennent ou
dans notre milieu il s'en passe beaucoup
c'est sûr qu'on a beaucoup plus de
chances j'ai commencé à apprendre que si
à la peau madame en acier à la peau mais
payés de la boisson non plus fait que je
pense pas mais j'ai déjà été dans un
milieu où on apprenait que jamais
non parce que je sais pas les gens que
j'ai vus en prendre je suis dans
certaines soirées ça me toujours me
semble qu'à ce moment là tu perds le
contrôle de dt faculté une quand même ce
serait sanaa pour quelques heures tu
n'es plus tu es plus à ce moment-là m 2
des décisions plus de devoir la vivre
vraiment en phase réel alors
personnellement ça m'intéresse vraiment
poche je serais pas capable de faire
parce que je trouve ça plus vallabrix
personnellement que de 2,2 vraiment voir
les problèmes en face de les prendre de
front
plutôt que de prendre le prendre la
drogue puis je suis pas ça change
changer la vision du monde
[Musique]